let me ask you guys a question kind of
that was that was important last week
because I ran a poll on I'm going to do
it live here so
um when you take a look around at
relationships
um sorry long-term relationships and
more specifically marriages like people
people that are living together
um and or married
um are they mostly female-led
relationships male Rhett male lead
relationships or equal Partnerships and
I'm going to put this as a poll in a
live chat I want to hear from you guys
on the panel show to sort of chime in as
I type out this poll but go ahead
female
what give it a question yeah yeah my
most
to be honest I would say that most
relationships start out as male
dominated and then gradually they
convert into female dominated before
they end
up that's a good that's a good theory So
based on where they're at in the
relationship or who's leading is kind of
an indicator of the health of that
relationship so if it's more the equity
type angle for the relationship maybe
it's on on the way out but could go back
to being malware that's an interesting
idea
and that pulls into live chat if you
guys want to take that let us know what
you think because I find that to be a
fascinating question when people engage
it I always get accused oh well you know
you're fishing for answers in the wrong
pond it's like no I'm asking guys to
take a look around at relationships
around them and state what are you
observing right hi I mean where I live I
live in like stereotypical American
suborbia and 99 of the guys that I know
that are married it's it's all I got
asked the wife you know yeah
every one of them
have to check in with the boss it's like
and and you know
um I don't see I I don't there's one or
two guys whose women look at them like
kind of in a way of awe and respect but
that's about it and these are guys that
really don't give a rat's rear which is
a good way to
to manage things in that sense yeah when
I go to the US it's always weird go into
any public place where there's a lot of
people it's like a mall or a plaza event
movie theater you know concert whatever
and you you notice very quickly that
most of the women are leading the guys
around like it's almost a lap dog like
they're a fashion accessory or a pet
it's kind of the it's kind of an odd
thing to see when you when you're not
used to to seeing that every day
um what's it like in Mexico City with uh
people you see around there Jared
kind of all over the place I'd say
probably more on the equity side of
things you do get you do get like your
old school Alpha guys here and you can
see that very clearly and then I'd say I
don't see as much as the female lead
here uh and if I do it's it's usually
probably a another Foreigner so I'll be
walking down the street and I'll see
someone that looks out of place so the
guy's a little kind of squirrely or off
or weird and then around the corner
comes a pale fat chick kind of chirping
bossing him around yeah that's usually
American that's how you can that's how
people can tell us apart down here what
about in Romania drugs
yeah I'm quite a bit surprised of your
answers honestly like we have some
female-led relationships right like
the woman is a prosecutor or a giant
Hospital yeah yeah
but it's very different like you don't
see them bossing you don't see them
bossing the guy around it's more like um
a tacit quiet type of
leadership so it's not the type of thing
which I see that you guys are referring
to where she's nagging him like we're
doing this we're doing that
uh where she takes the role of a male
it's more like the dynamic is different
because of her way of being
but it's still traditional in a way it's
kind of hard for me to explain right
traditional sense where it's mostly
male-led yeah and to get to that I mean
I think that women obviously manipulate
men and they're very very good at it
because they've learned how to do it
over thousands or millions or whatever
of years and so even in a lot of
male-led relationships suddenly the
women the woman does have a say in how
their relationship goes a big say
actually in other relations because
they're because because a lot of the
times they don't dictate the terms of
the relationship but a woman is the one
that ends in a relationship if it's not
on her terms a lot of the times
um let me just show you the poll results
that came off of Twitter because that's
some more uh broad spectrum as far as
um participants I would imagine in 2800
votes on this resulted in
64.9 saying that marriages around them
look mostly female-led
um and if we go to the chat here on the
generals meeting uh viewers there's only
34 votes because there's uh 85 percent
uh saying that they're female-led which
is which is still significantly High I
mean it seems like most people watching
this when they take a look around took
take a look around at relationships seem
to seem to notice that most of them tend
to be led by the women uh which no
surprise I think it's a strong indicator
as far as why we have the problems that
we have in the world today it's just
bizarre the way that that is but it is
what it is right what what is it I think
exception
um female lead or a woman-led
relationship like how does that look
like do you like she makes all the
decisions she plans the vacations she
decides what happens with the budget
she's also typically the kind of uh bad
boss [__] you'll see in the grocery
store where she'll be you know
disparaging her husband publicly in
front of other people because he puts
the wrong diapers in the shopping buggy
um those are usually the ones that I
would Define as female lead like like
they're the ones that make all the calls
and whatever
yeah and I I did notice that at the
Easter Eastern European wedding I was
there but I I discussed this the other
day with um our friends who you know
refers to them as Western turbos and I I
I did have a really good intellectual
discussion with him about it and I said
you're using the wrong term I said these
women are plugged in women they've been
told by Society advertising TV shows
that if you're not bossing your man
around you're oppressed you're you know
you're you're you're under his he's
oppressing you so what they do is they
become these you know I'm leading this
relationship I'm being the boss guard
and it ends up poisoning the entire
thing whereas if they were told you know
hey you go out and get a man who can
lead you who can allow you to be
feminine pretty be the woman in the
relationship and let him be the Sword
and the shield you'll be much better off
but they're not been told that they've
been told like you got to be you know
the pencil skirt boss girl running
everything and
yeah yeah I don't think it's a way
forward but it is what is happening it
seems I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out